mm-hmm
hello
welcome to the stream everyone thank you
so much for being here
boy howdy do we have a secret for you
today
um
this secret is probably the most
profound secret that I have ever
revealed on one of my secret revealing
streams if you've never been to a secret
reveal stream before welcome
um it is always a mind-blowing
experience but this one in particular
might be my greatest secret that I've
ever told in the history of my channel
when I discovered the secret
I mean
most of the time whenever I discover a
secret it's kind of numbed me to the
experience of understanding uh the inner
workings of how these entities and
beings are
but this one this one nearly ruptured my
mind from the inside out with the
profundity of the secret itself so when
I reveal it to you I'm just telling you
that you guys should
um mentally prepare yourself for a
complete reversal of your perception of
reality
because that's the only thing that will
occur once you identify the truth that
lies within uh the secret that we all
know and uh understands so just so you
know I warned you
I warned you before the secret was
revealed that you had a chance you had a
chance and if you didn't run away before
you knew what the secret was then that's
on you and that's not on me like I just
got to say that straight up that's not
on me
so
without further Ado and without
additional warnings because we'll
understand that at this point there will
be no more warnings for when I reveal
the secret it's out for good you know
and you can only warn so much
how you doing everybody Welcome to the
secret stream
um thank you so much for joining I have
uh something else pulled up at the
moment before I do
uh the actual secret activity that we're
going to be doing today
um but
you know before we get into that I just
wanted to clear up this last bit in this
power wash simulator level
um because it's a it's a uh you know
it's fine it's fine it's like a madame
zarone type
um
thing
no the the name was different matters
Madam zaroni's from Holes
I can't remember
yes
right the secret okay yes sorry I got
distracted um something about this
secret is when you think about it it
starts to slip from your mind it's like
trying to hold a fist full of sand
and if you squeeze it tighter it's just
going to slip through your fingers all
the faster and therefore with this
secret when you try to perceive it it
actually
resists being perceived and so the
perception that you apply to it uh is
counteracted by its desire to not be
perceived
um and I think like I might have
revealed too much in in personifying
this secret because yes it is
it is something to be personified
absolutely
um so yeah just stay tuned be prepared
and be ready because it's not really
even going to be so much that I'm going
to reveal the secret it's more that the
secret is going to reveal itself to you
you know what I mean it's gonna reveal
itself to you and for those of you I see
doubters in here that's actually not
real viewers those are um
manifestations of the Secret's desire
not to be known I don't know if you knew
that but now you do know that but be
careful because you'll often forget that
you knew the things about the secret
that you thought you knew when you were
like I won't be tricked again and there
you go again forgetting that you were
tricked in the first place do you think
this is the first stream that you
approached where I was going to reveal a
secret if you think it's the first one
it's not
this secret I've tried to reveal it so
many times
and yet if you've forgotten it
you might just have to try again
so I don't know if this one's gonna
stick
anyway
yeah it's all in SCP
um I'm almost done with this one thing
that I I gotta say about power wash
simulator is I would have thought that I
would have been bored by now and yes I
got more power wash Pals on the way I'm
gonna I'm gonna do more power wash Pals
don't think I'm not gonna do that
um but that's not what this stream is
about anyway
it's about the secret this is this is
not the secret if you think this is the
secret then you've clearly never been to
one of my uh secret reveal streams or
have you and you've just forgotten that
the secret was there in the first place
uh no yes or maybe also yes
so
what's the secret
that's what I've been trying to tell you
guys I've been trying to explain this to
you from the beginning and you just
won't look if you guys are going to be
impatient about it I'm I'm not gonna
tell you the secret because I don't even
know if you deserve to know the secret
if you're just going to be so demanding
about it you know
like what's up with that that's just
disrespectful you know if you think
about it that's just this is really
disrespectful
I can't believe it I can't believe it
maybe I won't maybe I won't reveal the
secret to you
maybe I won't maybe I shouldn't
it's pretty nice
that's not bad
all right you got me
all right there's no secret wink okay
you tricked me or you you saw through my
ruse you saw through my tricks there's
no secret wink yeah you guys can go now
you got me it's just a big joke there's
no secret reveal feel free to leave
leave now wink oh yeah go on go on
there's no secret don't worry there's
nothing here for you wink
no no no no no no please please leave
please get out of here aren't there
other uh are there other streams for you
to watch at this moment aren't there
people playing like Diablo 4 or
something that you should see I bet they
got some Secrets because I don't think
yeah I definitely don't have anything to
reveal at the end of this so you better
just like move on it's just going to be
nothing but me playing powerwall
simulator
maybe uh maybe maybe revealing a secret
yeah right no that's not true definitely
not so go on get out of here
get out of here
you found me out you sleuth you you know
what I'm up to always
a
secret now guys
I don't know what you want from me
there ain't no secret wink nothing's
gonna be revealed on this stream nothing
at all like come on guys it doesn't
matter how much you explore around in
the description there ain't nothing
there for you to see
like come on guys what do you think I am
what do you think I am what do you think
I am do you think I you think I plan all
this you think I plan this you think I
don't just hit live and then just like
oh I hope hope I figure out something I
hope I don't just buy time and waste it
so that I can have an excuse to play
powerwall simulator and then uh people
are gonna you know Clue Into the oh
maybe I don't have a secret you think
that's how I operate you think that's
what I do sure yeah okay all right okay
you need it you need it yeah all right
well
sorry pal
don't know what to tell you why is this
sign still dirty
is that actually dirt on the front there
no
no oh never mind I got it oh I got it
[Music]
podcast what are you talking about you
talking about the hit podcast
distractible you talking about the top
10 rated podcasts of all time uh video
exclusivity on um Spotify distractible
or you talking about go go my favorite
sports team now with guest episodes
no that's not what today's about
look guys
don't tell them our secret ah you know
what
maybe I shouldn't
maybe I shouldn't maybe I absolutely
shouldn't
they don't deserve it bay window cap bay
window frame
which one's the bay window
oh that's the bay window
Mark's too scared to tell the secret no
it's not that I'm scared it's not that
come on guys I'm
I wouldn't be scared to reveal something
so personal to you guys like we have a
we have a very special relationship and
you know I I trust you guys implicitly
explicitly I I I just trust you
because this this relationship's built
on trust it's it's foundational to this
whatever it is that we have
foundational guys
so don't doubt that don't doubt that for
a second because uh there's one thing I
do is trust you guys
100 percent 100 percent
thousand percent actually what are the
freaking chimney
how's that ugly
well I got something else
hold on guys I'll get to the secret in a
minute I'm almost done with this one so
I gotta I gotta make sure I do it right
there we go
out of the roof decorations
what
roof decorations what do you mean what
do you mean
what do you mean oh on the outside
probably yeah
one moment gang
two more
one more
oh
hold on guys
secrets on the way just you wait
just you wait it's almost here it's
almost time it's almost time for the
secret
dangle
thing you know it's um it's a bad habit
of mine that I start a stream and I
actually have intention and things that
I want to talk about and then I let
myself get hyper focused on One Singular
bit and then and like that'll take over
my entire thought process there's
nothing that would distract me from that
one bit and I just cannot bring myself
to ever get away from that single bit
because to me like the bit is everything
and therefore nothing can get away from
the bit
and then I just I hyper fixate on the
bit and then everyone's like oh dare you
how dare you
how could you do this to us
when in reality I did have something
that I wanted to talk about but oh these
are the decorations oh okay
all right roof
there are a lot of oh there we go
nevermind
there's a roof fascia
please archive this I will archive this
I absolutely will I'm so close
you know that that threw me off I was on
I was uh browsing through uh tick tock
on the other day and often I run into uh
tick tocks that feature my voice in One
Way or Another like I did and sometimes
I don't even recognize that they're my
voice like um which one was it and the
the one this was a while ago the one I
was like What if I didn't run what if
I'm not a coward what if I want them to
kill me what if I want them to try like
I didn't know that that was my voice
when I first came across that Tick Tock
and that's happened more than once but
there was another time where I came
across a tick tock that was like um it
was some automatic dough mixing machine
and uh
like it was it was just like the the
thing was that you were supposed to slap
it with a spoon in there and I was like
I thought about it for a second and I
you know in my head I'm like are you
close you close and I open up the
comments and the very first comment on
there was you close you're close and I'm
like oh my God
oh my God God I can't get A Moment's
Peace on this stupid platform I can't
get a moment's piece on this stupid
internet oh
I got one of the Aces Ruth Underside
okay
proof Underside
roof
oh it's the curtain thing ah
okay
oh I see it oh that's obvious
let's see this
I see it oh that's how did I miss that
that's egregious
Underside
hello move Underside oh there we go okay
Underside Underside
Underside
bunderson as soon as I get done with
this I'll tell you the secret I'm going
to tell you straight up what that secret
is don't you worry anyway I had another
point about that but I I forgot it
God I'm just the best YouTuber ever
there it was
okay is this the wishy washers
okay so the reason I wanted to do this
was because there was apparently some
big thing I cleaned that by the way I
cleaned that I cleaned that I cleaned
that I've been cleaning up a storm but
all on my own like absolutely on my look
at this look at this look at this look
at this look at this you looking at that
look at that look closer look at that
you've seen that look at that
look at that
oh that's nice
yeah I gotta try something real quick
hold on one second yeah that's a bore
spear in the background that's not the
secret don't worry about that I want to
try something because
um you guys know how I'm a professional
YouTuber right and I actually am good at
my job and I know exactly what I'm
supposed to be doing right
well in all honesty I don't often know
what I'm doing
um because For the First Time in Forever
I've actually found out that you can and
other YouTubers have been doing this for
a very long time now that you can
integrate a shop on uh the the the
channel so if you haven't noticed
I've actually got the product shelf
working which is a feature that was
brought about like three years ago
there's a secret I'm gonna I'm getting
to it I'm not gonna I'm not gonna reveal
it right at the beginning because then
you're all gonna leave anyway so uh if
you guys know about cloak
um this month uh 10 of the proceeds from
the free flow collection go to the
Trevor Project which is something we do
every year many times a year actually
um so if you want to check that out let
me see if this actually works if I do
this and I go uh did this work
did it work
what happened
did anyone notice anything changed
did anything happen at all
I don't know if anything happened
yes it worked
[Laughter]
perfect
um
[Music]
this isn't fee I'm I swear to God I'm
not
uh
[Applause]
I I don't know why but this particular
one is uh listed in the
featured in this video I swear to God
I'm not listing the I'm not wearing the
thing that just I swear I don't know why
it says that there's many things about
this that I haven't figured out just yet
[Laughter]
uh but uh trust me when I say like I'm
not wearing that one I bet it's very
comfortable I haven't tried that one in
particular but
oh man all right but anyway so that's
working
oh God
my internet
uh
oh I'm back
am I am I back
huh
I don't know what's happening oh I think
I know what's happening oh I know
exactly what's happening hold on
everybody
hold on oh
here we go
I could get out of that
yes yes yes let's quit that
yes yes yes good is that better Ah
that's much better good right
all right good it should be clearing up
now okay so that's working
um so that's one thing that I wanted to
talk about
which is good I know what I'm doing so
that's there and I'm a professional
YouTuber and also big big Movie Maker
did you guys know about that have you
heard of that one yeah that's happening
okay so that's good there all right
that's what I wanted to try that's not
the secret I promise you that's not the
secret I'm holding you hostage
is that what you think that these
streams are that somehow I am forcing
you to be here that I'm withholding some
deep dark secret that's gonna change
your perception of reality and you think
that you are being held here against
your will because you need to know this
secret and you absolutely must know it
and somehow I know exactly how to keep
you on the hook for longer and longer
and it might be related to Five Nights
at Freddy's and not really not really
you I bet you just went like oh wherever
you are standing in your kitchen
watching this on your laptop you just
went oh I bet you did I bet you did but
it's not because I'm holding you hostage
or anything but it's funny that you
mention hostage taking wink wink but
that's not me holding you here hostage
it's not what it is anyway
so um
what is that
ah
I don't know if I'm supposed to clean
that I don't know if it's a good idea to
clean that
I don't I don't know if it's a good idea
to clean this thing
what is where am I
fascinating
well this is different
is this thing going to come to I hate
this
I don't like looking at this thing
I don't like looking at things you said
for now
oh okay anyway so you're not held
hostage here definitely not
what the hell is this supposed to be
you know I don't know what's going on in
this place
there's a uh has matpat ever done lore
on this I think he said he did but
honestly who knows I have no idea yeah
stop predicting my facial expressions no
there's no no way I couldn't I could not
do that I could never not do that
um
see like I just start blasting this
thing it's going to end very poorly for
me
what is this Zone
this is a very different experience than
I was expecting
bird
can I climb up there no
okay I'm holding you hostage I don't
think I am yeah
whatever guys he he's just he's silly
whoa
oh that's a different color than I
thought it'd be
thanks for heading out all this way out
of town it's great to catch up can you
believe the quality of the statue this
thing is likely over 8 000 years old
well that seems
old
should I really be blasting this with
high pressure water
is that what I should be doing
it's also directly facing Mount rushless
almost like it's keeping
huh interesting you know you're right
almost like it's keeping watch and maybe
if I clean it it's going to ruin all of
its protective ability almost like that
almost
please tell secret I don't ah man at
this point
I think I've built it up so much that
it's just not gonna have the same punch
maybe I should just wait until next week
to tell it because I feel like it's just
like now you guys are all thinking it's
going to be a huge thing and trust me it
is a huge thing but I don't think you're
gonna like be able to appreciate just
how huge of a thing it is if I say it at
this point you know what I mean I just
don't know I don't know
I don't know what do you guys think it
is what do you guys think it could be
what do you what do you guys think it
could be huh what do you guys think it
could be hmm
I don't know I don't know if I should
guys I just don't know if I should all
right I'm gonna quit the bit there is no
secret
I've come out and said it now even
though I know no one's gonna believe
that I I promise you guys there's no
secret it was all the ruse there were
other things that I wanted to discuss
while I was here it's it was all of ruse
just to keep your attention there and
the bit got out of control wink and I
just couldn't let it go so there is no
secret no secret will be said and
there's no reason for you guys to be
here at all Facebook
it was all a joke it was all a ruse wink
it was all nothing
don't worry about it there's no secret
it's it's all just a lie it's a lie it's
a strategy to try to
keep people
just strung along longer and longer so
that you know I I can exploit YouTube's
retention time and then you know people
are like wow the YouTube's Like Whoa man
people really must love this stream and
yet they if any YouTube staffer were to
come into the stream they would see the
Wailing and gnashing of teeth and the
anger of everything that's going on
there it's all a ruse just like the rest
of my channel saw one big lie saw one
big lie guys ah man I don't know how to
say this
it's all a joke I'm not even really me
uh oh God I can't stop the bit guys you
guys seriously I'm trying so hard to
stop the bit and I just can't
you ever gonna see who's stuck in a loop
there's no escape from it ever forever
for the history of ever that's where I
am right now
There's No Escape
I am God
huh I don't think that what I'm doing
would qualify as edging you and I don't
like the insinuation so I'm not going to
give that any credence
yeah
it hurts physically what does what
physically hurts you think it hurts you
it hurts me our brain is broken trying
to come up with [__] ways to keep
this Secret dangled in front of your
face
what if it's
but what if it's real what if this is
just a 5D chess move because before I
was denying and I was winking but now
I'm not winking but also this could just
be a ruse like it could be true there's
no secret or maybe this is the ultimate
test and if you just hang on a little
bit longer
Maybe
just maybe the secret would be revealed
to you and those who were too weak
to stick around they left
and never know maybe that's it
see the secret actually is uh was within
us all along uh the secret was the
enemies we made along the way I don't
know if you knew that but it's true it's
a if I jump on this it's gonna curse me
forever
right anyway
um
I think it's time for the secret okay
now that we've cleared out some of the
the the chaff here where um it's time
for the secret
okay
no you don't know what's happening you
have no idea you you haven't got a clue
you don't know what's going on you don't
know how it's happening you don't know
what
I don't know it's true anymore
you don't know what's true you don't
know it's real
you're dialing up your friends like
there really was a synchronous about
no if I'm actually gonna show a secret
or just some [__] thing that you've
seen a thousand times you have no idea
anyway here comes a secret
uh
I wish I had done that differently
that would have been nice
relaxed
foreign
[Music]
yeah that should work
oh oh God
oh my God
the secret is getting unruly
uh uh is this
working
oh oops oops oops oh okay oops oops I
almost did something terrible I almost
did something horrifyingly
but it's okay it's okay
it's all good
uh
[Music]
oh Carl did I miss it
man you guys are just man you guys I
really riled you up you see I I uh we
made a discovery Amy and I that uh chica
really really likes videos of ducks
um and it's almost a problem right it's
almost it Riles her up almost too much
uh so we have to do it very sparingly
because it's it's a very particular
video of ducks not one but it's it needs
to have like a high frame rate it needs
to have ducks that are both quacking
very loudly and flying and you guys are
right now chica because it is just
this is astonishing see this is where
I'm like what if I what have I done and
I know that I just dig myself into a
hole because at this point even if there
is or is not a secret it would never
it would never live up to the
expectations of what's in your mind
oh man
I wonder if I could even talk about that
I'm so curious oh man I really
oh geez
I I
no no I couldn't
I couldn't I couldn't
I couldn't no no no no no not at all
no no no okay all right I'm coming clean
I'm coming clean there is no secret oh
where's uh the only fans set three so
what I'm gonna do oh but the only fans
thing is because
I've been busy with the edit for iron
lung that I have not had a lot of spare
time which is why I just kind of wanted
to do a live stream right here and just
talk in general about things and not
reveal a secret
um but
uh what was I talking about right the
secret
hold on guys hold on one second very
very important um
very important stuff going on right now
very very important stuff happening
occurring presently what I've literally
forgotten what the hell was I talking
about
I have ADHD in no sense or care what the
secret is I'm just here to make people
speculate more
because there's so many things because
right now I'm actually digging in to
things that would actually be a secret
because I'm like oh God what could I
possibly say that could build up to what
I have done and so so I I
no I can't I literally can't even talk
that's not a joke but it's just like man
I really really want to talk about this
one thing but I definitely
absolutely would get in a horrific legal
trouble if I talked about that
you ever just love sitting on something
that you know if you even spoke a word
about it that it would end Your
Existence forever I'm sure there's
plenty of Reddit confessions that are
about that but no no a Secret's not iron
lung how is that a secret I've I've
literally never stopped talking about
that so it's not that what it is why the
title then because I'm a Kremlin because
sometimes I just want to [__] around
because sometimes I just like it's not
even click bait it's just straight up a
lie the clickbait at least kind of
insinuates that there's something here
this doesn't insinuate anything
because I just can't help myself
because I can't help myself
but I actually do have many dark
terrible secrets
look man I don't know I have uh five
minutes that I want to just [__] out a
thumbnail
and so I find a picture of myself and I
type in the word secret and then I'm
committed into the biggest lie
I'm just committed into the biggest lie
and there's nothing I can do there's
nothing I could do about it there's a
seagull oh yeah there's definitely a
seagull oh yeah 100 uh
um
oh man
I love this
this
[Music]
oh wait I gotta hold on
hold on wait a minute
hold on
this
this nope this
okay so this is my own story the title
is and then my skin was rubbed clean off
wait no I got a better title okay okay
and then he flipped me over
uh-huh intriguing in Korea it's uh it's
a thing that they have bath horses or
some thing in many cultures and in these
bath houses you are naked I've been to
them before you know I've been to them
in Korea I've been to them here in La uh
but when I went to Korea last time my
cousin said something very interesting
to me he said you want massage
wow
and I go I don't mind a massage I like
massage and he goes oh you want massage
and uh I said yes and when we entered
into the bath house we walked past these
two Mass there and there was someone
scrubbed like someone getting washed
like physically washed like by another
person by another person yeah there was
another person the only non-nude person
in this entire bath house was the person
doing the scrubbing he had shorts on uh
so it was a bit of an oddity but I
passed it by because I was like I know
massage is from the Korean bath house
here in La so we go to the bath house
we're so can we relax and we have a good
time and then my turn comes to get a
massage and my cousin guides me to where
the massage is going and he guides me
right to the tables that the other guy
was getting scrubbed down on and the guy
has a scrub Rag and he flips it over his
shoulder a few times and slaps the bed
and he's like hop up is it the same rag
that he was scrubbing the other person
with uh now that I think about I do not
think he
I don't think he changed the wash he
just rang it out dipped it in the bucket
it's fine you smacked the table what do
you think the smacking is for yeah when
I got up there he got a bucket of water
and he just splooshed it over the top
and you know water ran off and clean and
instantly no problem there wow so I I
lie face down on this table I'm I'm
mortified but I'm like okay whatever is
I'll get over with it's a it is what it
is and this guy like this guy went at me
like he hated me everything about me
everything that I stood for was written
upon my skin and he needed to remove it
I just remember the most incredible pain
of just shunners the cheese grater of it
and my back was bad enough you know and
he gets every part of my back top to
bottom fully naked here too right yeah
uh so then he says uh some words to me
that I didn't understand the time now I
know he was what's your safe word but
he's telling me to flip over but I'm not
understanding it so we kind of like like
digs his hand underneath like my torso
and my legs and he flips me over uh and
then he continues just scrub and I'm
like okay I'm face up naked my Ghibli
bits are all out in the open but you
know it is what it is here we go and he
goes just as hard on my upper of my
front and then when he gets to my legs
he does this what I can only describe is
a long smooth motion that ended with him
pretending like my balls were not there
and he plows from toe to waste oh
smashing my balls out of the way like
bumper cars
getting in my inner thigh
I can only tell you this guy was
extremely thorough because it took three
impacts to get my whole inner thigh on
one leg before he switches to the other
side oh my God and you'd think he'd
start on the outside I'd like to give my
balls a break after being smashed to
bits no he starts on the inside on that
side
Direction all the way
just full connection I like oh it's just
he didn't give oh [__] so it was over
before I knew it and I swear when I got
up he had a cigarette somehow I don't
know how but he had one was it good for
you this is not even a joke but I only
remembered it afterwards when he was
done
hello
all right I'm back hey did you know that
if you want to see and hear more of
Amazing Stories like that you can check
out distractible through the link in the
description below if you like Bob Wade
and I we have two episodes of
distractible a week that we put up there
it's full of fun laughter and US
mercilessly making fun of each other
so that's what we do anyway where was I
right I remember what I was talking
about because I was talking about the
only fans thing so what I'm going to do
is because I was so busy with editing
the movie and there's just no time to do
all that and it's it takes a little more
work than you would think it doesn't
take that much work but does take work
um so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
going to go ahead right now because it's
been way too long
for that to wait around so I'm just
going to go ahead and get the charity
month the money to the charity I haven't
touched any of the money from only fans
but I'm just gonna go ahead and call it
good and get the money over to the
charity because I do not want that just
sitting in the only Fan's bank account
doing whatever that is so I'm just gonna
have that sent over to the um to the
Charities immediately and that way it's
just not waiting anymore because the
reason it took so long in the first
place is because all whoops I needed to
film a movie and it just happened to
happen all then at once and then there
and then I have kept you here for over
an hour what do you want from me there
is no secret
there's no secret there are secrets that
I could say but I'm not gonna say them
because it was all a ruse
it was all the rules it was a bruise
it was a ruse it was a ruse
it was a ruse
you've been bruised
this isn't what you signed up for I
think this is exactly what you signed up
for I'm pretty sure you knew exactly
what was going on when you hit subscribe
to this channel whenever the hell that
was
like it's only been 40 minutes yeah wait
a minute I held you here for an hour
I've only been streaming for 40 minutes
yeah wait a minute you called me a liar
but that person no I've been here for an
hour you have no perception of time you
got Bamboozled into another time Stream
So that you took longer than when I was
actually streaming for this is like the
people to say like oh I've been watching
I've been subscribed to you for like 15
years I was like I've only been doing it
for 11.
so how dare you lie to all of us at
least I'm being honest at least I'm
being honest
ah anyway like I said prior whatever I
said before is true 100
you knew what you were getting into but
I am gonna get the only fans money over
to the Charities because I do not want
that stuck there what's wrong with my
shirt what's wrong with your eyes
nothing is wrong with my shirt it's not
a paddle why does everyone think it's a
paddle it's not a paddle it's a very
sharp bore spear I'm gonna move it
eventually I meant to move it a while
ago and it's just like I don't know why
it's still there but it is and so
hush
it's fine it is fine everything is fine
it's all 100 fine and you don't need to
worry about anything it's not a paddle I
could show you I could show you that
it's not a paddle but I won't because in
order to do that I would have to take
off the Scabbard and that would reveal
the sharp edge and it's very dangerous
and you shouldn't play with weapons at
all ever
you should treat him with respect and I
know a thing or two about respect let me
tell you that it's a word anyway I don't
respect you enough to tell you the
secret
I just I couldn't
anyway so um uh Hi how are you guys
doing
it's good to see you again yeah I know I
know I know
it's good to see you again thanks so
much for being here
um I I've been able to get back into
semi-regular videos which is good
um but let me tell you have I ranted yet
about
storage
have I ranted about Thunderbolt yet if
you've listened to distractible you
might know my rants on Thunderbolt but
have I rant to you about how stupid
USB is have I because my God
I I don't even know yes I don't even
know where to begin I it's so
terrible
everything
about all of it is awful
every single thing about usb is a
nightmare
it's a landscape of horrifying this and
trying to manage files is just
ungodly it is against God
because I'm gonna tell you this this
might this isn't a spoiler or anything
USB C 3.2 times four no it's worse than
that if you think that's all it is
you're so oh you sweet sweet
summer child no let me go over this
with you let me see if this is gonna
work is this gonna work if I just paste
this here would it
would it work
nope nope
huh all right
uh
okay
copy
nope okay I gotta save it okay hold on I
know my way around
oh
what the frick oh no that's fine don't
worry about it don't worry about it
everybody
okay
okay I got it I got it I got it I'm good
at Computing this maybe maybe it's not
USB there's a problem maybe it's me no
it's USB is the problem because look at
this okay all right so I we're gonna go
through this a little bit at a time okay
all right hold on hold on I should do
this on the other thing but I'm doing it
here we're doing it here okay everybody
get ready so back in Yonder day we had
USB
back in Yonder day we had USB 1.0 right
so I it's slow this is way back when I
don't know when this was but it was a
long time ago then you add full speed
USB 1.0 still garbage then you add USB
2.0 and so this is what high speed yada
yada
it's it's fine right still USB 2.0 there
was just the one of them and that's good
that's right okay that's fair that's
fine nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with that at all that's fine no
complaints then came USB 3.0 and we're
like great 3.0 it's like 10 times faster
holy [__] this is gonna be amazing but
this is where things started to go wrong
so you had USB 3.0 and then USB
3.1 gen 1 came out which was the same
thing
as USB 3.0 but they decided to change
the name for some reason because USB
actual 3.1 came out which was double the
speed
but they decided to retroactively call
it something else because they came up
with USB 3.2 at which point USB 3.0
became USB 3.2 gen1 X1
which retroactively made USB 3.1 USB 3.2
Gen 2 x 1. remember it's gen 1 X1 Gen 2
X1 then 3 USB 3.2 could be USB 3.2 gen 1
x 2. clearly different
but then they were like wait a minute we
can double the speed and make USB 3.2
twice as fast using the encoding
protocol that we have for USB 3.1 but
it's just a matter of planes that we had
there so it's USB 3.22 John 2x2 which
was 20 gigabits because it had conformed
to the previous naming standards so then
USB 3. it was before came out
oh
anyway
so that should have cleared out all the
people that are too weak to know the
secret okay so thankfully good God I'm
glad I can stop that stupid rant where
it's acting like I'm actually care about
that [__] okay so all the people that
were too weak to get through all of that
should be gone right now is secret time
so what I'm about to tell you is uh man
they had to send an email about this to
everybody uh just to say like
I can't keep doing this I can't keep
doing it I can't keep doing it
technically I do have a secret but I
it's also something that I I shouldn't
post or talk about at all
man I could I could read you some of
this email though I really could I could
I could read and you would have you
would man even just like this one I'm
not joking me telling you this one
sentence would send you on wild
conjectures wild conjectures like
you would run with this you would run
with this so far
what if I oh God what if I leave this
what for God what if I look at this what
if it leaked it what if I did
what if it did what if oh man
oh
I'll screen you one sentence from this
email I'll just read you one
I'll just read you one
how what let me read my NDA
if you actually do that first
yeah let me see this let me see this let
me see this thing
seriously
this hmm what is this
um
oh wait where's the copy of it hold on
hold on no there it is okay all right
[Music]
no that's not right that's not right
that's not right no no no no no
there it is okay here we go okay got
this let me read this
okay
you the undersigned in connection with
your discussions with me
information maybe
[Music]
foreign
which may be in your possession and you
shall not retain any copies extracts or
other reproductions
okay okay all such proprietary
information is confidential that the
dissemination of any proprietary
information will cause company
irreparable harm not readily measurable
in money
okay all right okay all right well that
sounds pretty bad okay all right
all right I think that's that okay that
particular secret I can't talk anything
about
I'm so oh God I'm struggling guys I'm
struggling to find a secret that could
even be worth
discussing because it's just like
I I
just oh man
hmm
goodness gracious I just I I uh God I
just I mean I'm going to be in trouble
no matter what I do I'm going to be in
trouble no matter what I do so how about
this instead how about this instead okay
all right I'll put this instead
one second
all right
okay this is gonna this'll do
I'll be right back
how much I want to tell this I want to
hear it even more now
um when I was in high school I was
dating a girl uh we were together for
four years what's her name what's her
name I'm I'm gonna keep that one to
myself for now
yes
somewhere in the middle of our
relationship like a year two years in
three I don't know somewhere in there we
had made out fooled around a bit and we
hadn't had sex but I remember a couple
days later she's like hey
um I need you to get something for me I
was like okay yeah sure what is it and
she's like I need you to get a pregnancy
test and I was like excuse me she's like
uh my period's late it's never late I
just please and so I I'm freaking out
because I'm like we haven't even
does it work can that is it possible I
don't even know how old I didn't have a
car I don't think at this point because
I remember I remember I had to ride my
bike to Kmart oh no I had to ride my
bike to Kmart and I like pull up I park
it on the sidewalk and I go in and I
have no idea what I'm doing dude I'm
just freaking out yeah and I walk up and
I mean when I was younger I I don't know
if I still had the afro at this point
but I looked like an [__] yeah uh and
I'm walking around looking for employees
and I find somebody I'm like where are
your um can I say tests
I was like yeah
yeah my mom needs some pregnancy
I said it and I was like oh [__]
and they're like uh okay uh not
believing me at all oh wow yeah my mom
needs a pregnancy test so they'll leave
me over there here you go and there's
like I don't know how many options there
were at the time but there were options
and I was just like which one and
they're like well I don't know like they
look at me like I don't [__] know
what kind of pregnancy test how pregnant
might she be so I'm like looking looking
pregnant is your mother a bunch of guys
just like I don't know
yeah I had to wait in line for all the
other High School dudes waiting to buy
their pregnancy tests their bikes were
also parked up for their moms yeah
no they cover
they come with Mama pregnancy test yeah
me too yeah me three
how do I buy one I mean I had I'm not
gonna talk about the route I had to go
on but it was like a decent bite I'm
just on my bike riding home with a bag a
Kmart bag with a pregnancy test and it
just like sweating bullets from stress
thinking about the fact like what if
that guy knows my mom
and I remember I was like please don't
run anybody please don't worry anybody
and of course my mom's like in the
driveway as I get there like oh what'd
you do
what remarks like I just
for some reason I don't know why my
mental image but you have training
wheels on your bike and you feel like a
little hat with that spinny propeller on
the top of it I got a little horn I
squeezed
[Laughter]
what are all these kids doing last
episode
I'm sorry Mama you know we all had to
buy you a pregnancy test
boiler alert after my ex used it turns
out she wasn't pregnant and all's good
period started like the next day you
can't believe it yeah
I'd like to start by thanking my mom for
uh existing so I could buy that
pregnancy test under a very good uh good
look at look at the suggested video good
God
I don't think that should be the
suggested video
I thought that I set that to be another
one of these animations
um
turns out um
I guess I didn't that's that's not
a similar
the sign really doesn't inform what's
going on here that's that's not right I
don't like that
I'll fix that later
um hello welcome all right so I've got a
solution to our problem here I have a
solution right okay hear me out now you
really gotta hear me out on this one
okay
oh side note if you want to check out
more distractible we have video episodes
on Spotify now what does that mean it
means if you want to see us in person
doing it you can it is two episodes a
week
go check it out please
the please
I'm begging you
in here anyway uh so here's the here's
here's the deal okay so I know there's a
lot of people out there that are like my
God I want to know the secret and I'm
held hostage here okay all right so hear
me out hold on hold on hold on give me a
second give me a second
all right hold on hold on hold on what
are the days I don't know Monday's one
of them I don't know what the other one
is
um
so
here's what we're gonna do the secret
right the secret a lot of people have
left because they think that there
wasn't a secret but now you guys are
left over here I don't know why but you
guys realize that there's not a secret
so what we're gonna do is you guys are
all going to pretend like I told you the
Greatest Secret you've ever heard in
your life okay
and then you can launch it over all the
other people that did not stick over to
the end and you can act like you heard
the greatest secret that was ever told
but you are sworn to a secrecy unlike
any other under pain of torture and
death you can never tell another Soul
what the secret is but between you and
me we know that there's no secret but
that's the secret right so now everyone
who wasn't here in this moment will
realize that there's a secret because
you are going to suggest that there is a
secret and then when they go to this
video to look at this moment then they
will know the secret and the secret is
that there is no secret
right so now we've created a secret out
of nothingness and from this moment on
we will have we will act like the secret
is in the past so now until the end of
the stream the secret has been told and
anyone joining the stream in that moment
is like what's the secret and you all go
you can't you can't know
it it's unknowable right
okay
so that's it so from here on out the
secret has been told you all know the
secret and you cannot tell another Soul
the secret okay we're all good
okay
okay good
good very good you guys want another uh
you know
I love those things
I love those things oh how about I wait
no here how about a go one how about a
good one
it's because I like them because they're
great
they're good so the basis understanding
of American football there are two teams
do you have 11 players on either side
there are three phases of football you
have your offense you have your defense
and you have special teams but there's
two teams there's two teams each have
three phases three
three it's so during competition one
team Fields offense one team feels
there's a third team waiting behind The
Stance ready to Ambush no no the special
ops like special ops special teams
special teams do you could equate that
to special ops they murder so your
offense comes out on the field you have
five offensive linemen five a
quarterback a running back a tight end
tight end and then you'll have three
receivers three receivers that's eleven
you're good at math thank you they can
run the ball which the quarterback will
receive the ball from the center via
snap between the legs okay could you
just keep snapping it forever could you
make like a chain of 11 people and they
all snap it between their legs all the
way back to the corner I mean you could
but you'd probably would lose or it's a
trick they're so confused the defense
would just tackle everyone no that's 11
in a row you're gonna get through 11
people no and strong you have 11 people
on defense yeah but there's a they're in
a row so they hide their numbers
what's stopping the football players
from stacking on each other's shoulders
to get rules and Defenders
[Music]
tried that so yeah there's technically a
rule in the NFL where you cannot utilize
another player to launch yourself but it
would be sick as hell though what about
two people heave hoeing someone that's
again launching but that's using two
people doesn't matter it's still
launching
all right what um generally speaking you
will see that kind of off snap they'll
snap the ball to the quarterback and the
quarterback can do one of two things is
he called the quarterback because there
are four of them no oh there's
technically a half back as well without
that's that traditionally now two
quarterbacks on top of each other in a
trench coat with like a fedora on their
head it's like you morph two together to
merge into the half back and then you
morph two half backs to get a full back
and that's like a Shiny Pokemon card you
know super rare but very valuable that's
why they trade players because it's like
trading cards right sure
all right I'm sorry I'm sorry continue
sorry continue so at the snap of the
ball quarterback get ball quarterback
throw ball ball catch defense tackle
quarterback get ball quarterback throw
ball defense catch ball turnover
turnover yes quarterback get ball
quarterback throw ball quarterback pitch
ball running back run forward
quarterback handoff ball running back
Run To End Zone touched so let me just
give a recap of everything that I've
learned so far certainly it's from the
very beginning yeah there's a special
team like special ops they sneak up
under the field under the darkness of
night all the people don't know because
they're camouflaged on the field they
have lines painted on ghillie suits that
look like the field and then they emerge
right and people don't know when the
game starts until they pop up out of the
ground and then they go and kick the
ball and then the other team who was
hiding in a secret formation out on the
receiving end they pop up and then they
catch the ball and they run it as far as
they can and then they switch out
there's an offense team and a little
defense team we don't know about the
defense team yet all right okay we've
talked about the offense let's talk
about the defense defense stop offense
going to touchdown defense stop offense
from getting 10 yards in three defense
stop ball defense stop offense from
score points okay all right I'm gonna
give a summary of everything we've
learned so far so after the Special
Teams parachute into the stadium like
under the cover of Night Radio silence
underneath radar level they're dropped
in speed drop helicopter but a silent
helicopter
no error nothing just
oh
and it comes in and drops parachutes
they come down this is like midnight
next day game goes kick boom it's on
they pop up from the fields
guns are blazing across the field
bullets flying everywhere the other team
catches the ball they tackle him they go
down the offensive is trying to sack
that ball was it
don't tell me they're trying to S
between the legs Wham they snap they
snap the ball snap it right now they
crack it
boom to the quarterback he throws or
Chucks back or runs himself try to get
ball forward the defensive lineman they
don't take [__] from nobody they've been
bullied their whole life they don't like
anybody no human animal nothing they're
full of hate nothing but hate they want
to stop that ball they're like
psychologically controlled from their
birth to hate balls
and they're just like No And so they do
whatever they can whatever dirty trick
knives whips chains I don't judge to
stop that ball from going forward and
that's football
[Music]
I'm back all right well done gang well
done well done well done all right okay
well uh I think
that is
oh time to watch the statue so oh wait
no you can't see what I'm doing you
can't see anything that I'm doing yeah
thank you thank you I I did do well and
I'm about to do well on this thing
oh my God
so uh now that the Secret's out
um like I'm just happy to be able to get
that off my shoulders
um because get that off my chest I don't
even know what the right expression is
um just because that's been weighing on
me for a while and I mean it's been
weighing on the people that did that it
applies to
um
probably the most oblique way that I
could possibly say that but yeah so glad
to get that out there I don't need to
repeat myself and I know that you guys
are all gonna you understand the
importance of keeping that to yourself
so thank you very much for you know
really respecting
um the sanctity of the secret yes
you know the secret yes you do and
remember don't tell anybody about that
okay that's just between us it's a very
special thing
trust that we share is
um all we really have if you think about
it that's all we ever have it's just
trust so
uh
yep keep it secret keep it safe
interesting
you just got here uh well sorry you um
well I mean you missed out I think I
don't know I don't think you can
I just don't wanna it's just too painful
to talk about it again so I won't
uh I mean if people break the rules and
try to tell you the secret I mean I
can't really stop them but I know that
like they understand just how much
it means to keep that super super secret
so
thank you everybody
thank you one and all
anyway time to clean this
I don't know how this happens I don't
know how every single stream I ever have
can't be normal
I don't know why it's just a constant
flow of nothingness just for the sake of
nothingness and not actually something
where I'm like hey I want to talk about
you know my life and my thoughts and my
feelings and it's like Donna
rile them up
rile them up real good make them
question everything they've ever known
about you make them question why they
ever came to this channel in the first
place do that do that instead do that
instead of having a nice personal
relationship
I don't know why I don't know that's
just it's my modus operandi
chica was adopted chica that okay all
right I listened to distractible not
tell the secret thanks thanks for that
listen I'm not going to tell you the
secret unless you get distractible back
to the number one spot above Joe Rogan I
won't
oh never ever ever tell you the secret
no okay all right Secret's over secret
oh God secret time's done there's no
more talking about anything don't worry
about it it's fine it is what it is uh
or it isn't what it isn't it's let's
just move on okay let's move on let's
just all agree that that was a fun
Excursion
that is what it is and it's all gone now
excuse me it's all gone
it's all done we need not dwell on it
anyway it was something else that I
actually was going to talk about but
I've completely forgotten at this point
uh
uh I don't know
yeah well whatever how are you guys
doing how about that how about we start
over let's start over
let's get back to the basics let's just
get down to something that we can all
appreciate and understand and just just
just relax a little bit everyone's been
so wild up riled up everything has been
so chaotic we just gotta talk about
there how am I feeling I'm feeling good
I really am I'm feeling great
um I'm getting in a nice steady Rhythm
I've got all the ranting done with the
file management 90 terabytes of footage
is finally being managed properly which
is very nice
um and I've learned more than I ever
wanted to learn about
like Network attacks or attached storage
direct attached storage all that stuff
I've learned everything I could possibly
want and more about that and I never
want to know anything about it ever
again
because it's just it's just not worth it
yeah but I'm doing good I'm falling into
a good Rhythm this this uh shoot
it was a tough one it really was a tough
one it like dwelled on me a lot it was a
lot of weight I thought it was going to
be easier than it was
um especially coming out of like space
and you've heard me talk about that
stuff but this one
this one was a Tuffy this one was a real
toughie so it's nice to get back into a
rhythm it's nice to be back home it's
nice to be able to like just not have
the the film schedule Sprint that I've
had before it's nice to uh feel like I'm
getting back on top of the channel
because that that was a big stressor is
like not being able to post videos for
like
two months that was awful I I don't know
um if you guys understand it but this is
like that was legitimately
painful for me not to be able to post
content not even like oh I'm taking a
break and I'm posting comments like to
not to not have a choice and be like oh
I can't because I got so much work that
I need to do that that that's no good
that's no good at all so it is nice to
be back and just be able to just make
content again there's something so
so peaceful about just making regular
old videos there's something so
like rewarding about making bigger
projects like what I'm doing with iron
lung here but at the same time it's just
like man I just freaking love just
sitting around and just watching [__]
you know what I mean I guess that's a
lot of that Shadows overloading yeah
Shadows oh man I do gotta get back to
that
damn it I forgot about I will finish
that one I love shadows overloathing I
love those types of games they are a fun
Excursion they're a bit slower paced but
God funny I play so many like scary
games I sometimes forget that I I just
like an enjoyable like funny experience
like just a game that's just there for
fun
and you know it's kind of hard to get
that when everything's so dramatic all
the time but yeah I mean that's that's
kind of just like the whole point of me
making stuff in the first place is just
so it can be fun you know
that's that's just what it's got to be
for a lot of people it's just got to be
fun because if it's not fun then why are
you doing it you know if you don't enjoy
what you're doing the way you do it and
with this you know it's the weirdest
thing me playing power wash simulator
and saying that statement because for
the longest time I did not enjoy this I
was like this is arduous this is painful
and yet here I am still like years later
maybe a year I don't know how long it's
been out still playing it just for fun
just because it's actually like
satisfying to do
and I don't know how to explain that I
don't know how to Rectify that yeah
there's that
FNAF bro you gotta say something about
that I don't know how to explain this to
you uh that uh number one I can't and
number one I I won't
um because it's like what what would be
the joy in that well what would be the
goodness in that I mean sure you all
could uh run away and tell everybody and
then you could be the one that knows but
what's what's the point of that look I
don't even spoil my own projects like
it's it's not something that I would
ever talk about so
it is what it is yes live action power
wash simulator when uh you got to go
back in time to when it's honest to get
that I think
that's probably where it all started
right
oh did you know that you could turn the
red nozzle did you know the red nozzle
has an ability to turn it
because I swear
that wasn't always a thing but
apparently it was it's been a thing so
who knows
ever heard of a game called Shadows of
Doubt no I have not
I have not
um
when is iron lung coming out uh as soon
as I'm done editing it and as soon as
the visual effects are done much like
with all of my projects it comes out
when it's done
and it won't come out any sooner but I
am looking very much forward to being
able to share that with you that's going
to be
that's going to be cool now that I'm
actually in the weeds of editing because
I've been wanting to get in the weeds of
editing for a while now but I just
haven't been able to because of uh the
file situation but now that I have
gotten into it it's like
oh this is a cool one oh this is cool oh
it's very cool it also reminded me that
like I miss doing the who killed Market
Markiplier stuff
um not in terms of like doing ego stuff
but also just like going out and making
random [__] just wherever and
however you can I think that is like the
key to really falling in love with
production because don't get me wrong I
like having a set I like having people
that are very good at what they do I
like having a crew you can trust and
that you can build a relationship with
um but they I also just love going out
and filming [__] with your friends I
love just like what we did with who
killed Markiplier was just like we
rented an Airbnb and we just did it like
there were no rules there were no
anything to it it was just like we did
it and that's all there was there was no
other way to do it because we didn't
know anything else
um but that didn't stop us from doing it
because
doing it is what we love to do and I do
want to get back into that because
man it's just
it's just like such a wonderful thing to
be able to make [__]
so lucky to be able to do what I do I
know that and I try to remember that and
I try not to exploit it all this time
with streams where all I do is talk
about this great big secret that you
guys can't tell anybody about
definitely not
um but yeah no I'm I'm pretty lucky to
be able to do what I do
and uh
I swear
that now that I've gotten back into a
rhythm of making content that content
will be coming very regularly
extremely regularly accurate
because I don't want because while I'm
editing this and and I've gotten lost in
editing round of it rabbit holes before
because I do like editing and I like the
process of editing but I sometimes let
myself get consumed by things
yeah what is there can I do the voice of
warfstash God I hope so
I I don't know it's sometimes you fall
out of practice of things and they just
go away
but uh
we'll put that I don't know uh unless I
had a reason to do it and get it back
into it I wouldn't just do it really
that's silly don't say such silly things
am I excited for the Silent Hill 2
remake I didn't know that they were
making a Silent Hill 2 remake I'm kind
of out of the loop of a lot of games
need a new three scary games well you're
in luck because tomorrow there's going
to be the 99th episode of three scary
games and that means that the one after
that is going to be the 100th episode of
three scary games so that's um
I mean that's kind of going to be a big
deal I think unless it's not I don't
know maybe it won't be who knows with
these things but I think it'll be a big
deal maybe May haves
when can we watch iron lung or was that
where uh it's gonna be in theaters I'm
just having devised which ones just yet
so
working on it every uh like all I'm
concerned about right now is getting the
movie done in the best way that it can
be and that's that's all I care about
because um
I just need to see it to the Finish Line
before it can even go past the Finish
Line to anywhere else
yeah
theaters internationally uh I mean I
don't even know how the hell that works
but I'm sure that there are people that
do and so I'll talk to the people that
do know that and then
go from there I know it's like a demand
thing right that that's what it all
boils down to
um so this is kind of the advantage that
I have that many people do not when they
are making movies
um is they don't already have an
audience that likes the projects they
make so I am lucky enough to have you
guys that you for some reason or another
like the projects that I make
um so there's no question about me going
hey yeah I want to put this in theaters
and there's no one else that would ever
go like oh but are you sure you can sell
theaters and I'm like
I have about 40 million subscribers
yeah I think I can fill a theater
and they're like one and I'm like
yeah I think I could fill more than one
theater and it's like
so and I know that probably sounds super
egotistical to say to you guys which is
why I never say it and why I have to be
like
you're really gonna
really gonna make me say this out loud
I'm not here to brag but that's just how
much they don't understand the world
that we exist in and like it's not just
me it's like
creators online
just have all like there are people
there and there's like you guys are so
supportive of what I do and you're so
supportive and other people are like
have these wonderful audiences that are
just supportive of what they do and so
their creative Ventures
um it's not just a a shot in the dark
you know it helps that I've made
projects like this before and you guys
have watched them and enjoyed them
um and you trust that if I'm gonna make
something and I'm gonna I'm gonna put my
whole more [__] into this I hate myself
and I I'm I formally apologize for what
I just said and I I people are leaving
the theaters
I apologize for who I am as a person
listen I regret all the things that I
have ever done look at me look I look
come here come over here come here look
hey
um I've been watching too much tick tock
I apologize I've been watching too much
Tick Tock from like a year ago I
apologize for who I am I am cringe ABS I
own it and I accept it and
I apologize
for nothing
I
I don't know what I'm doing
but uh yeah no that's that's literally
the conversations that I've had many
times and it's kind of um to go back and
gloss over everything that just occurred
um
no that's that's the thing so but as far
as internationally I have no idea yeah
but that is the thing that is the thing
um that is the thing is is
these traditional and I talk about this
I I say the word like traditional media
whatever it's it's sold it's old old
media it's the old way of thinking about
it
um
I had a uh a conversation
about you know the movie and it was
talking about the uh the trailer
and
it was someone who was impressed there
was a few people I'm not gonna name
names here but it was someone who was
like really impressed with like the
performance of the trailer on my channel
and they were just like wow yeah you got
like almost five million people watching
this trailer how much did you have to
pay for to get that many eyes on it and
I went
of what what
no I what and it was just like because
in the traditional sense if you wanted
to get your movie out there and you'd
have to advertise and you'd have to pay
your marketing campaign get a company
going and stuff like this like no I just
no it's like who did you who did you
have cut that trailer for you and I went
like no I
I'm I made it I made the trailer because
I like making trailers I make fake movie
trailers for ad campaigns I just I like
it and it's just the mentality of that
someone could possibly even do that
themselves is unheard of right it's just
not a thing so it's not even in their
wheelhouse and and that's kind of like
the advantage that I have but also the
disadvantage and I've talked about this
many times before where I have to
literally like
teach people teach people about how any
of this works when I don't even really
know how any of this works you know what
I mean it's just you guys are still on
something else I'm talking about
something you guys are still just on a
completely different wavelength at the
moment
you guys are dwelling on something else
yeah man
uh so it's just
it's just
so um
it's uh it's uh it's fun you know it's
fun but also I don't know how
International works because it's got to
be like translator stuff like that
guys please please guys please
let me live
just let me live that's all I ask just
sons of the forest look okay this is one
of the things that uh
uh I I realize also has fallen aside
because I know you guys really won like
sons of the forest uh but the problem is
the problem is
um I'm
very lazy I'm extremely lazy and now
that we're doing distractible two times
a week so it's like Bob Wade and I you
know we we play those games and that's
what we've done we've done that forever
and I could schedule another recording
session with them we could play that and
do that but I am
I am really lazy and uh it would oh man
playing games for a couple hours with
the boys it sounds like it would be so
easy to do and you're right it would be
but I'm lazy and I don't do that
and you know how it is when you're lazy
and you just don't do something for a
while
and today would be a perfect day to do
it because it's like the weekend and you
know I could just call up the boys right
now he'd be like let's do that thing and
he'd be like wow sons of the forest
but then um
I don't do that
oh yeah Resident Evil 4 remake God I uh
I get so behind on these things because
I I let it fall to the side and then
it's like oh it's so late and I know
I've done all the other remakes and I've
played a lot of the Resident Evil games
but it's also just like
oh man I was just like a long play I I
can't commit to something like that it's
just oh my goodness
so it's like you can see where I am
layers of fear remake layers of fear
remake
wait
what
what are you talking layers of fear even
is it it's not even that old is it
why is it getting a remake
what what
are you trying what
what are you even saying
who is this hold on wait what is
happening
why is this like this
I don't understand what's going on here
how is there a remake of this
when
I just I don't
I don't understand
I don't
how
is
that
hold on hold on one second wait I gotta
gotta find this
okay okay ah
because I didn't even play all of layers
of fear I didn't
um but at the same time
feel okay cinematic intro here
it wasn't even that long ago
okay here we go
uh
God
boom okay
I'm good at OBS guys
what is this
[Music]
I once had it all
my palate was seated
nostrils stimulated
standing venerated
then one day
you took
everything away
shame and pain
[Music]
I'm still not sure what game you're
playing
but I'm back
[Music]
I'm taking what's mine
there's a demo
[__] I missed the demo God damn it
content con see but I don't understand
why is there
why are they remaking it
as opposed to making like layers of fear
too that's what I don't get they made a
layers of fear too
what what what if I missed when
did I miss how did I miss that I haven't
thought of layers of fear in a very long
time so I don't know what that's all
about but
well I missed out on it that I missed
out on it I missed something about it oh
well now that's that's what it is
interesting
it's fascinating
hmm
okay anyway little nightmare suit look
guys I'm not a good gamer I'm not a good
YouTuber I'm I I don't even know what
you want from me
help help wanted too
what
what is that
what do you mean what is it happening
Help Wanted actually that's pretty dope
I I liked help wanted the VR one that's
VR right
hold on I'm pulling it up I'm pulling it
up
yeah
welcome back
and minimal social interaction
we know how challenging it can be to
find a place where you feel that you
truly belong and to find a job that
treats you mostly with respect and only
infrequently with contempt
for that reason we are excited to inform
you that you did an adequate enough job
the first time around to have you back
also
there were no other applicants
so strap yourself in and get motivated
to an appropriate degree
because you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
all right well that's cool well that's
all right I'm okay with that so it's
interesting that they got the same voice
actor to do the same lines but they
didn't put the same effect on his voice
so it seemed different whereas before it
seemed like a pre-recorded you know
thing for whatever have you in the yada
yada is that it was whereas this one was
like um
something seemed off about it but that's
okay I I like that they got the same
voice actor back again for that uh
wording was a little different than it
probably was sons of the forest trailer
no I'm not gonna do that
I gotta do that look look shush shush
all your faces I I'm getting back into
the swing of things with getting in into
games and stuff like that I'm making
content so it's all fine it's not all
about the games
sometimes it's about
something other than the games you know
sometimes it's about something other I
know there's Outlast trials I know that
I know all these things I I know this ah
man I I do I do I got it I know what is
I don't even know what you're talking
about FNAF one trailer
so the Five Nights at Freddy's one
trailer the original is that what you
want is that is that what you want
is that what you want I have no Clash of
Clans
new three scary games tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow
it'll be there tomorrow
FNAF ruins what does it even mean what
are you talking about
there's security breach deals what
that's what you were saying see when you
just say ruin I don't know what you're
talking about
you're just gonna say ruin and accept
expect that I know what you're talking
oh my God okay
um
interesting I think well let's see I
didn't think that they were even gonna
touch this game again I didn't think
that they were gonna have anything to do
with this
Cassie I hope you get this message
I'm trapped here at the pizza boxer
what's left of it
don't have time to go into how I got
here but you've got to help me out
Cassie please
go dark down here
[Music]
Gregory run
don't give up on me yet
I won't I think you know it was
fascinating July that's right around the
corner
content it's worthless content so here's
the thing I actually I had a lot of
problems with security breach but I look
back on it fondly that's the thing and I
I I know that probably I don't even
think that Scott was happy with it or
whatever I haven't asked him I don't
know
I think Scott is not happy with me at
the moment but
um it's uh it's one of those things
where like I liked that experience I
liked what they were going for I saw a
lot of problems and I saw a lot of
things but I could almost understand
them you know I could almost understand
them
um and it's
it's just like I look fondly on it I
enjoyed that experience so I am I am so
down uh to to play that I'm I'm really
because it also came at a really like
opportune time for me specifically uh I
needed that game uh just for content to
play but also just like
um to keep my YouTube channel like uh
pumping while I was working on something
else and just like it was just like a
very fun one to be able to like go into
and get frustrated at and go for it so I
actually liked it I liked it a lot it
was it was very nice I thought it was a
good time
FNAF movie trailer I don't know what
you're talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
um
know what you're talking about
don't know what you're talking about pal
don't know what you're talking about
never heard of you let's get out of here
I'm calling security
calling Security on you if you show your
face around your River again
hmm what are you talking about I don't
know
I don't know what you're talking about
just never say words to me ever again is
is um
if you ever if you ever say words to me
I will sue you just like I'm gonna be
sued
for sure
I already looked at the trailer for help
wanted to
the question is
am I now a FNAF reaction Channel
am I the king of five nights or Freddy's
reaction trailer reactions is that what
I am I like but look guys I there's I
love a trailer as much as anybody else
but as far as making content about
simply reacting to the trailer I'm I'm
very not about that I'll watch a few
here and there just because it's fun and
it's it's interesting to be like oh I
didn't know that was a thing but uh
let's not make it a habit guys let's not
let's not make it happen
yeah
please something other than horror games
what do you what do you think I'm doing
unless you unless this is a horror game
unless you're telling me that power wash
simulator is a horror game like I've
always suspected it is
there's something going on here
there's something going on with this
volcano and now I'm cleaning a big
statue
something weird is up here you know what
I mean
I'm not right
very not right about it
Resident Evil 8 VR
uh
Resident Evil Village VR
like
you could play that
NVR see everything up close and personal
in Resident Evil Village
is what you're saying
well
I'll have to look into it I'm not sure
uh
I'm just not sure about that one I got a
lot of schedule
conflicts that I have a very busy I'm
such a busy man I'm such a busy busy man
I don't know if I could fit it in I
don't know if I could squeeze it in to
my schedule
so I'll get I'll get back to you on that
get back to you
oh yeah it's about power um but you know
it's about other things too besides just
power
a lot of things about power but I don't
even know why you brought up power
that's very strange of you to say such
things
very strange
did you know you could rotate the red
nozzle I might have mentioned that
before very useful skill when you're
washing
thing
so is it just uh What uh Resident Evil
vrs is that like just on Playstation VR
or something or is it on um
that on like any VR
can I do it on any do I have to stream
to my PC for the VR to work right or um
that's something else that I gotta do
for that
psvr exclusive huh
right and so um how much is that these
days
how much is that these days that these
are these days how much is one of those
just asking anybody got one that they're
selling
anybody what the frick
aquatic ape Theory who is talking to me
Sonia Alamuddin
that sounds like a fake name unless I'm
being disrespectful
the prehistory living semi-aquatically
like Atlantis are we talking Atlantis
here
talking Atlantis did I see eldering DLC
yeah I saw it but I mean unless there's
a trailer drop in it and nothing to get
excited for yet it's probably going to
be a very long time
before that comes up
although I I did watch a video just
recently that was talking about
um just Elgin ring and just reminding me
of how much I love that game and how
wonderful it was when it came out the
time that it was
what a game
what a freaking game
anyway I don't know about this aquatic
human Theory but that's what that is
uh will I continue Callisto protocol uh
probably not it's been so long maybe in
a stream but there's been so many games
that I've started not finished I I think
that might be one that's doomed doomed a
pile
so I don't know if you guys
maybe just mourn that one I apologize
yeah subnautica three oh that's right I
haven't even played subnautica
cold the cold one what is it called I
for Arctic
oh man I should play that one that's
just that's a fun one
I gotta get back into it because one I
can do by myself that I believe the
Frozen one is now
plead so it's got a full finished
experience not just going through the
betas again that would be fun
I would like that and notice how I'm
picking a game and I'm like oh that
would be fun for me to do that's what's
important
gotta get the fun first you can't just
put everything before the fun and you're
just not doing anything you want to do
oh no it's got to be fun
oh man how did I miss somebody
yeah
below zero that was it below zero thank
you below zero yes
yeah so that would be fun
I wouldn't mind that
dredge uh watched Amy play dredge a bit
seemed fun but I didn't really see
enough that would make me make episodes
about it
yeah
Doom DLC I know that came out so long
ago and I'm probably due to play it but
I I things just got in the way of it and
I wasn't able to actually get it done so
unfortunately
yeah there's a lot of games I know oh
you know what I feel bad about
I feel really I feel really bad about
this I in that video where I was like
need some help when I was filming the
movie and then
um I asked for like the person who made
the video game suggestion list to
resurrect it and bring it back and then
I said like I swear I'm not gonna do the
thing where I ask you to put in all this
work and then not play a single game on
your list and then I did that exact same
thing again
where I didn't play a single damn game
on that I'm so sorry
I am sorry
for nothing I
I'm sorry for nothing
it's uh it was a risk you knew the risk
sometimes that's the way that it works
so I apologize
anyway enough game talk enough game talk
what else is going on people's lives
what are people worried about right now
it's almost summer here in LA
apparently
if the rain would stop
it blew Wade's mind when we when Bob and
I were talking about the fact that it
was raining in California and he was
like it rains California there's there's
no way that's impossible it never rains
and it's like it does there's there's
weather out here and it's been freakish
weather these days
yeah
what are we talking about you guys are
still talking about other things I've
moved on
I've moved on you missed the secret the
Secret's long gone
see the secret is so long gone
like that's that's such an old
conversation at this point
I gotta really get in the nooks here
well between that
yeah
straight no that's game no
help it's so glitchy I think that's just
on you I don't know if there's anything
I can do about that
I think you just might be glitchy
but I'm not 100 sure
cloak brand do you not know cloak at
this point is this an excuse for me to
talk about cloak oh hey how's it going
there somebody doesn't know about close
brand
well let me tell you it's
just the clothing company for you it's
my clothing company for you specifically
why don't you just uh check out some of
the amazing offerings that we have uh
actually I do because uh 10 of the sales
for the free flow collection go towards
the Trevor Project so if you don't know
what that is you can read up more about
it on the website or go to trevorproject
and check out their mission there but
it's a worthwhile cause and um all the
stuff that we have in our collection and
I I swear that we do not just support
like
we do not just support on June we do it
many times throughout the year so go
check that out there
um what else was I talking about before
I got distracted by that yeah
but
there was something else
I forgot
oh I talked about the only fans thing
I'm not going to do a third drop right
now I'm just gonna get the because I was
waiting while I was filming the movie I
just didn't have time
um but what I'm gonna do is uh I'm just
gonna go ahead and get the money over to
the Charities so that way it's not
waiting on that
um because I don't want to I don't want
to hold it well I'm not even holding on
to it I don't want only fans to hold on
to that for a second longer before the
money gets over to the Charities so I'm
gonna go ahead and do that probably
first thing on Monday
um and get that over and then in the
future if I ever need to promote
something heavily I will save the extra
only fans stuff for that moment so they
they're I gotta keep uh I gotta keep the
people somewhat thirsty so that I can
have something to
to uh leverage for the future of my
content dreams maybe something for the
iron lung movie I can tie into that and
thirsty bastards
and then you won't have anything to
complain about right no nothing nothing
but it is very important that I get the
money to the charity as soon as possible
so I'm gonna do that
oh you can't see how long have you not
been able to see
what
how long have you not been able to see
how dare you not be looking at the game
this is on you like I can't believe that
you guys let it go that long
I feel like that's gaslighting and I I
don't want to be a part of that one
I don't want to be privy to that
not that the entirety of this stream
wasn't gaslighting but
it is what it is anyway I started
talking about why would I go full screen
on my face just to talk about cloak that
doesn't seem
in any way productive in any way why
would I do that I I want you to stop
lying to me
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
that's actually not cool so I'm not
going to do that
nah but I am going to rant about a
secret for like a very long time I feel
like a really long time yeah
I feel like a very long time
I don't know where you're at but if it's
anywhere near muckingham then you need
to get out right now what
what
Mount rushless could blow any minute and
I'm I'm just praying I've got time to
scoop up Ma and paw
what
is that what
am I responsible for this for cleaning
the statue that's looking at Mount uh
Mount uh exploding goo
can I put this up here
it's in my view of the mountain
I'm very strong by the way
don't know if you knew that
very strong
oh boy
well [__] all right uh I guess we're in
trouble maybe or maybe we're far enough
away I don't know something like that
um
gotta get under the bed
it's your birthday in five days oh
congratulations oh happy birthday happy
birthday for all of you anybody whose
birthday it is happy birthday
you know I did a video on trombone champ
and that's going to be a real [__] post
of a video because basically all I do
for the entirety of the video is [__] on
the game because its whole gimmick is
that oh people are gonna be bad at it
but
I literally do everything on the
computer with my mouse and I know a lot
of people are like well of course I do
that too no you don't understand I do
art with my mouse on the computer I've
done all of my thumbnails with my mouse
on my computer and many of you know this
but what this translates to and also I
do powerwall simulator with my mouse
because and I do extremely precise
control stuff so what that means was I
was actually good at trombone champ
therefore there was no moment of haha
I'm so bad at this so it just was like
the whole video is me just [__] on
the cake
oh dear God please I hope you can make
this funny and he's like I'm trying man
I'm trying
yeah oh sucker for love voice right okay
I'm gonna get out of there all right
I'll remember that
that's not that big a deal
so uh anyway so yeah no I one of the
reasons that I'm getting better at it is
actually because I'm just playing a lot
of this game right here which helps me
with precise Mouse control
because when you have precise Mouse
control you can really get in the
grooves you can clean out the gaps
and not all that stuff
this statue wasn't such a big Honker and
this would be a lot easier because I
like back in the day when I was first
playing this I would have just run
around with the white nozzle and just
been like no
wait where's my where is it
what
the frick
this novel
weird I don't know and then just trying
to like blast out like that and that's
not how you do anything
nope it just takes precise control yeah
favorite b-day prison I don't know I
haven't gone yet
play music you play music why do I need
music you could play music on your own
it wouldn't change your experience you
could actually control the volume that
way I'm giving all of you an opportunity
to play your own music That's How kind
and thoughtful I am
what's up
not much how are you good to see you do
I still play trumpet absolutely not
oh damn hey Mark hello how are you good
to see you
how are you
worst two hours of your life or best to
almost two hours of your life I
being here
oh power wash VR is happening
I need to use the bathroom can I pause
the game absolutely not there's no
pausing this
but if I need to use the bathroom then
yeah because at any minute this volcano
is going to blow and we're gonna see
some lore happening apparently which
will be fascinating
quite a dirty under tit
I am so Ohio
I don't know what that means
I'm not a hundred percent sure
cuphead DLC look guys do you guys think
that I actually care about games that's
the crazy thing is you guys think that
I'm some kind of a gamer and I'm not
that's the thing people think I am but
I'm not I'm an imposter I don't even
really care about games I care about
some games but I don't even really care
about games anymore I'm nowhere near
where I once was I am a false gamer
I am not the gamer you think I am I
don't play games I've never played games
I don't even like games
I don't like anything about games
I've never played a game in my life
ah
Ultra kill great game love that game
yeah go on look I'm just I'm trying to
concentrate here I'm gonna finish this
up
you actually I got something to
entertain you
foreign
I have a terrible idea right now I have
a terrible idea
I don't even know I could do it right
now I got a terrible idea
here what am I do
that's a terrible idea look guys you you
guys are just you're too much right now
that's always the worst idea ever
um you guys are just too much I have had
enough out of you and your sass
I'm leaving
I'm out of here if you can handle me at
my
best
you don't deserve me at my worst
hold on here why is that one not working
come here you
there it is if you don't deserve me in
my best
I don't deserve you your worst and you
don't deserve nothing how do I do I
don't know how to do hold on hold on
okay we got this
then you don't deserve me at my
bestest
you don't oh frick you don't deserve me
at my best
you don't deserve me at my best
I freak
you
I've added up to I've had enough of you
and your worst so you're not gonna get
my best
you oh you don't get the best of me
cause I'm not gonna give the best to you
so why aren't you there we go okay got
it okay wait is this gonna work
oh it works okay cool all right you
don't give me my best
what am I gonna sing uh so I don't get
you at your worst so you're gonna go to
this
2007 freshman and I'm Gonna Keep playing
in the background
so I come in from winter break I I open
the door and you know Bob's there and
I'm just like
ah
let's lock the beds
like I don't think I said hello first I
think I like walked in the door and was
like you want a loft you want to put the
beds in on top bunk them you want to
Bunk the beds Well we'd have so much
more room for activities that way I know
God that movie hadn't even come out I
know that's exactly what
was for when people come over when we
have all these parties obviously we're
cool guys you just throw a lot of
parties after this yeah sure yeah yeah
yeah
definitely threw at least one
[Laughter]
so Mark enters and so our current setup
we basically split the room in half
right but it's not that big of a room
like if we were standing shoulder to
shoulder we'd probably take up the whole
width of the center of that room yeah so
if you bunk one bed on top of the other
you get like a quarter of the room but
the way the beds are supposed to go
together when you bunk them you're
supposed to one lower the height of the
bed that goes on top because when
they're on the floor the bed is like all
the way up on the highest setting it can
go right so you can put stuff under it
okay but if you leave it like that and
then put it on top of another bed
there's like maybe a foot between the
bed and the ceiling yeah really like
legitimately so you're supposed to
change that but that required like tools
or I don't know knowledge
we didn't know how to do that so we
didn't do that of course not so we're
looking at this and we're like yeah I
don't think we need oh we can't adjust
your bed I think and Mark is like that's
fine that's fine I'll sleep up high good
air up high it'll be fine
like we get past that hurdle the other
thing about this is other than the fact
that you're supposed to one ask for
permission and two ask for help from
adults there's supposed to be a thick
metal pin in each of the four legs that
lock it in place so that they can't slip
off that seems crucially important and
then we're looking and we're like all
right metal pins metal pins we don't
have metal pins and I don't know I think
it was you Mark I gotta I gotta give you
credit where it's too we're sitting
there like brainstorming and Mark like
goes into his wardrobe and turns back to
me with a pair of scissors and a plastic
clothes hanger
and it's like if we just snip this
straight part of this clothes hanger
it's like metal pins it was the perfect
size it fit perfectly it was the right
diameter it has I'm pretty sure plastic
clothes hangers you can snap with your
bare hands have the same tensile and
sheer strength as metal pins so like
yeah he looks at me and of course he
holds up the scissors and the thing and
I look at her and I'm like perfect
how big do you think they need to be
let's do this no hesitation at all
and my favorite part of this whole thing
we eyeball them to the same ish length
set them all in we Hoist the bed up
really precariously set it on the pins
one of the four pins was like half an
inch longer than the other ones and it
was half an inch too long
so the bed the weight of that corner of
Mark's bunked bed which is now like 10
feet off the ground the weight of that
bed is sitting on the plastic clothes
hanger and we sort of like I don't
remember the conversation but we looked
at it for maybe a second like 10 seconds
total and then Mark was just like ah
[__]
Mark's bunk bed one quarter of the legs
was supported by like a quarter inch
thick piece of plastic you should be
[__] dead
[Music]
all right
did you enjoy it was that good
good good that calmed you down that
calmed you right down that calmed you
right down I'm glad about that all right
now I know you're not gonna do that
again all right because you learned your
lesson right
and you apologized and that I accept
your apology
and we'll just move on from this
almost done with this so this thing's
about to blow
um and I don't know what's gonna happen
when it does but I think it's gonna make
um everything dirty again that's my
theory is this uh volcano is gonna blow
it's gonna like reset all of the
cleaning things and wipe everyone's
memory at the same time and then I'll be
like man I guess I gotta clean
everything in that's my
that's my guess
I'm probably right
God damn this thing's still dirty I
guess I haven't cleaned it from the
front yet you don't see it
oh God you don't see anything
man I am a good dude oh man that's I am
a good whatever I do I'm good at it I
swear I said yes I swear how is it not
on that screen it's the same thing it's
the same oh no I thought I was changing
it
I thought I was changing it
I really thought I was I don't know what
to tell you I thought I was
anyway I accept your apology is what I'm
trying to say do you see me you see it
now yes you do yes you do absolutely oh
it's very quiet you need the sounds
there we go
almost done I'm at 94 on this thing so
it actually is pretty close to done
just got to give it a little more
scrubbing some spots
and then I think it's gonna go kaboom
I'm pretty sure everything's gonna go
kaboom
which would be stunning because
I don't know how I'm gonna survive this
guy was going to get his mon his paw and
I'm pretty sure they're doomed
wow
it's goddamn under tit
the pressure washer is too loud see
that's the thing uh you're wrong uh so
about that you're very wrong there's no
way that it's uh
that you're correct
be patient everybody that's what this
game teaches you you got to be patient
you were on the WC
you got writer's block
any advice
um
I don't know
I I've been inundated with writer's
block before
um
my only advice and it's not the most
helpful advice is uh right stupid and I
know that sounds like a joke but I'm not
joking
um
if you're working out a certain plot
point
and you're like man I can't connect this
story or I can't connect these
ideas or these themes or whatever yada
yada whatever fancy [__] you want to
say just write stupid I'm not I am
literally not joking write as if you're
an idiot and write poorly write terribly
just take some time and just write what
you think and what you would believe
would be really bad stuff and then just
keep writing that as if you were trying
to connect to the plot points in your
own dumb way and in doing so what that
does is it's kind of fun to just let
loose and write some garbage and that
makes the pressure of trying to write
perfectly
go away
um and so when you're writing dumb you
might make yourself laugh you might
explore a different idea you might put
on paper something that you dismissed in
your mind as a bad idea and then once
it's on paper you're like oh wait a
minute if this was slightly less stupid
this might actually work it's just a
brainstorming
um so yeah if you're ever stuck in
writing while we still can right before
Chad GPT takes everything away from us
um just just write dumb like you know
the the AI writes dumb so why not write
dumb a bit it doesn't need to be perfect
and then getting it out of your head is
the more important thing in my opinion
and then
you'll let other people tell you that
your writing is dumb but if you write
the dumb first you know that it's not
dumb and then nothing they say can
bother you right that's how it works I
think
I think yep
what's this I don't know man I'm just
I'm just washing I just felt like wash
and you ever just feel like washing
sometimes you just gotta wash and this
game has taught me a lot of patience you
know I always say like in terms of ADHD
therapies that meditation is a is a big
part of it in a way
this game alone
has helped my
patience incredibly
and
it's so strange to say that a game would
do this but in the same way that like
Tick Tock can rot your brain from the
inside out and is the absolute worst
thing that you could do if you have ADHD
I just today deleted it I had to
um
I do think that there are certain games
and lessons and practices that you can
do that will help you in the long run
and that's absolutely true because
otherwise the individuals like therapies
and and things that you can do for ADHD
wouldn't work at all and this is one of
those games that does especially if you
do it in a way that is
controlled focused patient and not
embracing chaos which I do sometimes
embracing chaos can be fun even in this
game
um but the methodical nature of It kind
of lends itself towards
this patience and sitting down and doing
something that is not immediately
rewarding and will help you in the long
run right
I do sometimes play music but you guys
can play music on your own I don't feel
like playing music because it's hard for
me to talk I might get in a trance where
I'm just in my own head right
so when I when I play this game and the
reason that I like it so much is because
it does kind of teach me to just sit
down and be patient and think actually
what I'm doing in addition to like other
things obviously like I can't say that
this is entirely what I do because I do
take medication you know I take a
medication called a Stars which I think
is better than the old medication that
was I was on for various reasons that I
don't need to get into right now
um but in addition to that it is
important to take your steps
and actually apply
the kind of mental exercises that you
need to improve yourself and even if you
don't have ADHD I think this game and
playing it in this way
can um can be a benefit to anybody
that's trying to learn patience because
patience is something that not a lot of
people have and especially when you when
I get questions like what's writer's
block and stuff like that it's it's just
like or what can I do for writings block
like a lot of it comes down to a lack of
patience because sometimes
patience is what you need things do take
time and they're going to take time and
they're always going to take time and if
you don't let it take the time that it
needs then you're not going to get the
results that you need you know what I
mean
I think anyway do I have a good view of
the volcano good okay
so sometimes you just gotta have
patience and this game teaches me
patience which I like
there's a face slab there that is not
clean and I don't know where it is
I'm not saying none of these are saying
that it's not
fixed
where is it
I'm impatient
yes what's the secret I don't know
what what the [__] what would happen if
I didn't take my fanaafel medication
my FNAF woman what's a falafel
my Five Nights at Freddy's pills oh God
I wouldn't know what happened would
happen if I didn't take my snap pills
Jesus can you imagine oh wait there it
was
right there ah got it okay so that was
the last few slab yeah
like an apple pills
look man at least you're not calling
them the ass pills anymore
[Laughter]
yeah
no thanks yeah
I'm assuming
that what you mean is what would happen
if I didn't take my ADHD medication it's
not like I would blow up or anything all
of it but it's also like important to
know and I say this all the time it's
not magic it's not gonna instantly make
everything suddenly uh perfect it's all
like um
it's all in blur it's all steps right
I'm just getting this out of the way so
my view is not obstructed
can I put this down there
um no but it it helps right that's
that's all it is it's all part of the
process and I I like I I need not get
into the details of like
um
ADHD I talk about it a bit uh but I
don't need to get super into the weeds
of it FNAF pills are suppositories
probably I would I wouldn't doubt that
um
oh god oh oh oh [__] oh god oh
well even if that's calming though oh I
think it calmed the volcano
well um
I did it
that's not a bad clean
it's not a bad clean that I did right
there what's next stunt plane boring
uh what was I talking about I've annoyed
how do I deal with the ADHD paralysis is
that like sleep paralysis
I'm not 100 sure what you're referring
to there
um but is that like the indecision
factor which is a something that I I
deal with
um
no kablui no sadly no kablooey there
yeah uh it's it's a challenge right that
it's tough there's no one answer to
everything and I'm not perfect at it so
I can't even say that I beat it all the
time the the hard answer is that like
it's always a problem even even on the
like even with everything working in
your favor you're doing everything you
can to try to work with it you know
sometimes you have bad days and that's
it
um sometimes you're stuck the the best
thing is just like and I know it's bad
advice because it doesn't help is just
like yeah no just just
you gotta still do things and it sucks
and sometimes it's bad and sometimes
it's awful
but that's just the way it is sometimes
uh I I I really have no other advice
besides that
um besides all the things I always talk
about but again don't need to go into it
too much detail about things
I talk about it a lot
I don't know maybe I talk about a lot it
seems like I talk about it a lot
I'm happy if I can help someone but I'm
also not an authority I only have my
experiences and they are probably
different
yeah yeah oh the games oh the games
again
talking about meds maybe I should take
mine
um yeah I I feel like that's that should
be a given I if if you have a
prescription for something that is
important outside of ADHD or whatever I
I encourage you to take it
as prescribed
Hello nice to meet you for the very
first time ever
why
seems like a relatively easy clean I'm
gonna go haphazard on this one just
because I feel like it so this is what I
would do if I was doing Chaos Mode
because it just seems like a very simple
clean which I don't mind I don't know
what the hell happened to this plane to
get it this safe I don't know if it's
blood
could be
damn this is an easy one I understand
you'll be working at my private airport
I will be relying on you to show the
utmost discretion we have some of the
most important and secretive people in
the world coming in and out of here so
whatever you see that is not to be
discussed with any other human is that
clear
what it's been two hours thank you yes
sometimes streams last several hours
that they do
but are you waiting for the secret the
secret was already told it was told at
the one hour mark
somewhere in there
looks like this is a job for soap
only yesterday we had a private jet plus
fly in
uh-huh go on
it was a crazy good secret that it was
it was a pretty nuts secret it was
pretty fantastic I'm not gonna lie it
was pretty great
who knows what was in the briefcases
they were carrying
tell you nothing tell you for nothing
that it wasn't stationary
now if you went around telling that to
any Tom Dick or Barry we'd all be in it
what are you talking about man
what are you talking about
what the hell is he talking about
I'm just power washing
I just cleaned things man
I don't do anything else besides just
clean things
I don't do any secret government
nonsense I just power wash
here in hunger what are you what are
people talking about fear and hunger
I don't even know what that is that a
game name or is that just like people
are talking about my fear and my Hunger
I'm power washing to survive yeah
apparently apparently I saved the whole
city
found something else amazing in the
desert another historic moment I what do
you mean why do you need to power wash
it
wouldn't that damage it
I feel like that would just damage it
Every Day brings new reasons to keep
your mouth shut that is the most
threatening statement every everyone has
ever said to me what are you talking
about
oh a celeb couple flying out tonight God
you don't need to start off a
conversation with every day is a new
reason to keep your mouth shut
jeez
that's what I say to you guys if you
ever Spill the Beans about my secret
every single day that you breathe
there's another reason I keep your mouth
shut
so don't tempt me okay you're gonna keep
that secret with you to your grave don't
tell a soul I don't care what they do to
you I don't care what they give you
don't if you do
you know the punishment
you recognize them right away they're
from that new hit film Bill Shakespeare
about the poetic duck
okay
I don't know what you're talking about
man I don't know anything about anything
man I just want to live
I just want to live my life
you're telling the authorities I don't
know what you're talking about
but I do know that if you don't keep
your mouth shut you're gonna need more
than authority to help you out of that
trouble
do not no no
what is this name called I want to play
this power wash simulator
you don't know power wash simulator you
don't know about the hit podcast power
wash Pals do you know about power wash
Pals do you
want not Powerpuff Girls power wash Pals
the power wash podcast the power wash
Power Hour
I have all those names they're all
trademark no one else can copy them
they're mine and mine alone
huh the pp
the pp yes you guys know about the pp
good
Mark what's your opinion
it's my opinion about what
what's my opinion about what
about what
better not be that thing you're supposed
to keep your mouth shut about that's for
sure
TB forever fear and hunger is that you
want to know my opinion about fear just
like in general
like I guess if you think about it from
a evolutionary stand Point fear is a
very useful survival uh thing because if
you're fearful you're attentive and
paranoia is only paranoia if you're
wrong and so it's it's it's just like
something that I know it's can be
inconvenient especially in today's
society but
from the standpoint of survival and
survival alone an extremely useful
tactic makes people very you know
expending energy because attentiveness
requires energy and you know to have
energy sometimes being afraid you know
is useful because it allocates your
energy but if it's not allocating your
energy properly you know that's going to
lead to issues of hunger you know
they tie in hand in hand is that what
you want to know about
is that what you wanted to know about
get iron lung to Canada we'll buy many
tickets I'll try that one's probably
easier because you mostly speak English
up there I know there's many people that
speak French but even they probably a
dabble in English on occasion so that's
easier an international sell than um
foreign countries that need translations
I think anyway again I don't know too
much about it so I'm going to rely on
the experts to guide me through
but otherwise I don't know anything
I know nothing at all
and those stains are really going to
need some like soap
I very rarely use soap in this but
sometimes the oily ones really need some
soap
I'll give this a once over with soap
once I'm done
please play Amore I don't even know what
that is
miss this strange cave billionaire
power wash the oil
in Sweden uh I'll do my best again
fear and Hunger Game I don't think
that's a game I don't know what you're
talking about have I ever baked bread
maybe I can't speak definitively on that
answer because I don't remember large
portions of my life
um
so it's possible
uh
uh but I don't know
um Egypt
is it's a country
so I hope that answers your question
thoughts on Zelda
um
sheep
blonde I think hair
thoughts uh none none thoughts about do
I have five onions no do I have five
ovens no
uh I hope that answers your question
thank you
thoughts on clock
I have no idea what that was even
referring to uh but many thoughts
pertaining to time uh my thoughts were
lost to time actually when una's honest
perished uh
uh rip and piece Memento morgue
um
thoughts on FNAF
uh Scott cawthon is angry at me and with
me and all around me
uh
uh thought over
um
probably I'm gonna say probably probably
don't know for certain
don't know for sure
um behind me okay
uh
uh why is he angry at me oh
I don't know
said probably I don't know for sure I'm
just guessing actually I know exactly
why who
man that stuff is just in there hold on
one second I gotta get the soap out I
never have to get the soap out hence why
I have so much of it but I do on this
one
good God
soap is like misleading because soap can
seem like it's gonna be very useful but
it it actually is not very consistent in
its spraying
um it just leads to a lot of problems
where you'll think something's clean but
you'll see that actually oh wait no it's
not clean at all
I missed a giant spot over there and
it's really annoying because you got to
hunt it down later so I never start with
soap I I think starting with soap is a
mistake
um I think using soap is largely
unnecessary but sometimes
sometimes it is because you gotta you
gotta ship like this
seems like it's clean but it's not
we go
I'm 99 there and it's still not there
what's going on here
okay let me just use the uh
thoughts on thinking
I don't know
thoughts on tiny bunny oh yeah that was
that game the like visual novel like
Adventure click game thing that I just
said correctly in that thing
thoughts on thinking uh thinking's cool
thinking's pretty dope like thinking
like thinking about stuff I also like
not thinking not thinking sometimes is
really cool
um
this game definitely helps with not
thinking so sometimes that's very useful
there it is
okay
inner Wings Direct
this one actually is annoying I'm I'm
very disappointed in this one it's more
annoying than I thought it would be
horizontal stabilizer
what is elevators
elevators
elevator
Melody
oh elevator
exhaust is there an exhaust on here
what
oh
all right one second gang no no I'm I'm
so close to done
I was gonna put you in time out again
but I'm not gonna do that I'll just be
mean
horizontal stabilizers I thought I did
that
stabilizer oh
oh
this is a problem with going haphazard
you don't know what you've done
because you never finished anything and
that's the bigger problem is if you
never finish anything you don't know
what you're doing
propeller blade
there we go rudder rudder hinge
okay Rudder hinge
Rudder itself
there we go and rear wheel support
that one took a while
all right
okay thoughts on Mental Health very
important Resident Evil 4 remake
thoughts on luxian what a sweetheart uh
uh thoughts on gentian impact I tried
playing it once it didn't work
um
thoughts on lady
dimitrescue very powerful thoughts on
little nightmares too no idea what that
is uh thoughts on children's education
in Zimbabwe vital I'm sure
um
thoughts on dogs love dogs uh Chica
loves Duck videos thoughts on friendship
very important thoughts on Portugal
That's lyxian's Country I think he owns
it I'm not 100 sure
um thoughts on cuphead old game thoughts
on cheese love cheese
songs on cats thoughts on Stockholm
Stockholm like the place
I have no idea
thoughts on this will change your mind
boo
ah look at these slippers
look at those uh thoughts on other
YouTubers uh they sure do tube those use
um thoughts on musics
uh thoughts on Minecraft I never did
finish Minecraft I meant to
um thoughts on well I can't read that
thoughts on new amnesia game oh yeah
there's one coming out I never finished
the old one because I never got a chance
to because it broke on me that's a
finger
you guys want to see a finger
it's a finger
I don't know where it's pointing at but
it sure is pointing hey wait there's one
too many fingers
all right
what is that about
anyway
so uh thoughts on carrots thoughts on
myself and my ego I think that I'm
pretty cool but I'm not so unbelievably
egotistical that I think that I'm better
than everybody else I think that much
like everybody else I have things that I
can work on and improve on myself and
that's one of the big driving motivators
in my life is that I always like to push
myself to do new things and try new
things and always move forward in my
life
um I was I stream for a lot longer than
I thought I would I was uh I was
originally just intending to stream for
a real quick time
um pop off a few promotional obligations
like I do but this was fun I had a good
time I had a good time on this
um and we we definitely uh got deep into
the secret the secret has been told and
you won't tell a soul and then
everything else will fall into place
after that
um in conclusion all the things that we
discussed remain just between us you
never tell anybody
um and then everything will just be nice
and fall into place
um
and that's all that we need to know
about that
good any last uh things before I leave
uh there are last things before I leave
uh be sure to go to cloakbrand.com I've
got a new product shelf down there you
can actually see the things down there
but all of the free flow uh drop 10 of
the sales go towards the Trevor Project
so definitely check those out if you
want to help support a cause or make a
donation directly to the Trevor Project
please feel free to do so
um also
distractible go my favorite sports team
go check those out we're now exclusive
with video on pot on Spotify we have
audio everywhere but video can only be
found right on Spotify if you want to
check that out go check it out
um
why is there a spear in my room
you got it right thank you very much
thoughts on iron lung very excited for
it lots of cool stuff coming can't wait
to bring it to you and just um
have a lovely time have a lovely day uh
move forward with everything that you're
doing with conviction
um proud of you proud of everything
you've done proud of everything you've
done so far so have a good day have a
lovely evening and I will see you
tomorrow because tomorrow we got another
video coming and more cool stuff
happening
thank you how often do I stream not
often and not for long this is probably
one of the longer ones but thank you I
am leaving what's that stick in the
background well
we could hand it on a good deal but I
guess we're not going to do that so I'll
take care of
goodbye